The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN: All right,
so I know some of you
have succeeded to do the
homework and some of you,
I think, have not.
Is this correct?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM GREEN: OK.
So I was wondering
if someone who
has succeeded to
do their homework
might comment on how small a
mesh do you need to converge.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: It's about l?
L?
OK, so you need something on
the order of l to converge.
Is that correct?
So if you're trying to
do the problem using
mesh much bigger than
l, you should probably
try a tighter mesh.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: Yes.
Yes.
All right.
And has anyone managed to
get the [INAUDIBLE] solution
to actually be consistent
with the [INAUDIBLE] solution?
AUDIENCE: Something
like 3% or 4% or so.
WILLIAM GREEN: 3% or 4%, OK.
And I assume that the
[INAUDIBLE] is also
using a mesh of similar size?
Hard to tell?
AUDIENCE: I used like
a triangular system--
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah, yeah, but
I mean, it's really, really
tiny ones at the bottom?
If you want me to blow it
up, I can just take a look
and see to be sure.
All right, and is backslash
able to handle a million
by million matrix?
AUDIENCE: Like 10
seconds with [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM GREEN: [INAUDIBLE] OK.
So you need to-- so do
the sparse allocation.
And MATLAB is so
smart that it just
can handle it with a
million by million,
which is pretty
amazing, actually.
That's a pretty big matrix.
All right, sorry,
this is too loud.
All right, so last time, we were
doing some elementary things
about probability.
Actually, any more questions
about the homework problem
before we get started?
AUDIENCE: What's the answer?
WILLIAM GREEN:
What's the answer?
You could ask your classmates.
Any other questions?
All right.
So I had you confused a
little bit with this formula
probability of either
A or B. So I asked what
the probability of--
I flipped two coins-- that
one of them would be a head.
And I could see a
lot of consternation.
The general formula
for this is it's
the probability of A
plus the probability of B
minus the probability
of A and B.
It can't just be the two
of them added together
because if you have 50%
chance for head of the penny
and the dime is 50% chance,
this would add up to 100% chance
that you'll get a head, but
you know sometimes it's true.
So this is the formula.
And then the
probability of A and B
is often written in terms of
the conditional probabilities,
the probability of A times the
probability that B would happen
given that A already
happened, which is also
equal to the other way around.
And this has to
be read carefully.
It means B already
happened, and then you
want to know the
probability of A
given that B already happened.
So it's sort of like this way--
I don't know-- the
way I think about it.
Like, this happened
first. and now I'm
checking the probability
that that's going to happen.
Now, a nice little
example of this
is given in
[INAUDIBLE] textbook.
And I think it's nice enough
that it's worthwhile to spend
a few minutes talking about it.
So he was--
[INAUDIBLE] who
wrote the textbook,
was not actually
a numerical guy.
He was a polymer chemist.
And so he gave a
nice polymer example.
So if you have a
polymer and the monomers
have some big molecule,
and at one side,
they have a sort
of acceptor group,
and the other side, some kind of
donor group-- we'll call it D,
I guess.
And these are the monomers.
And so they can link together.
The donor can react
to the acceptor.
So you can end up with
things like this and so on.
So this is the monomer.
This is the dimer.
Then you could keep on
[INAUDIBLE] like this.
And many, many, many
of the materials
you use every day, the
fabrics in the seats
that you're sitting
on, the backs
of the seats, your
clothing, the binder
holding the chalk
together, all this stuff
is made from polymers like this.
So this is a pretty important,
actually, practical problem.
And so you start
with the monomers,
and they react where you have A
reacting plus D, over and over
again.
And we want to understand
the statistics of what
chain lengths are going to
make, maybe what weight percent
or what would the
average microweight be,
something like that would be the
kind of things we care about.
So a way to think about
it is if I've reacted this
to some extent and I just
grab a random polymer
chain, any molecule in there,
and I look and find, let's
say, the unreacted D end--
so any oligomer is going to
have one unreacted D end.
You can see no matter
how long I make it,
there will still be
one unreacted D end.
And I'm neglecting the
possibility this might
circle around and make a loop.
So assuming no loops,
then any molecule I grab
is going to have
one unreacted D end.
So I grab a molecule.
I start at the unreacted
D end, and I look
at the A that's next to it.
And I say, is that
A reacted or not?
So if it's a monomer, I grab
the D. I look over here.
The A is unreacted.
So the probability
that it's a monomer
is going to be equal
sort of like 1 minus P
where P is the
probability that As react.
So it didn't react,
so just like that.
This one, the one next
to it has reacted.
So this is just going to be
the probability of a dimer is
the probability that my
nearest neighbor reacted
and next neighbor
is unreacted, right?
Is that OK?
So I can write this way.
I could say, what's
the probability
that my nearest reacted times
a conditional probability, next
unreacted if nearest is reacted?
So far, so good?
You guys are OK with this?
So I grabbed a chain.
I'm trying to see
if it's a dimer.
I'm going to calculate
the probability
that this next
acceptor group has
been reacted to a donor group.
If it has reacted,
then I'm going
to check the next
one after that.
So this is the nearest neighbor.
This is the next
nearest neighbor.
And I want this to be unreacted.
If that's both true,
then I have a dimer.
If either one of those
is false, [INAUDIBLE]..
Is that OK?
So now I need to
have a probability.
So what's the probability that
the nearest one is reacted?
There's some probability
that things have reacted.
So this is going to be my
P, probability that things
reacted.
And I wanted this
to be unreacted.
Now, there's a question.
Are these correlated or not?
Now, in reality, everything's
correlated to everything.
So probably, they're correlated.
But if we're trying to make
a model and think about it,
the fact that this thing
reacted at this side
doesn't really affect
this side if this
is a big enough [INAUDIBLE]
So to a good approximation,
this is independent of whether
or not it's reacted or not.
So this is still going to
have the ordinary probability
of being unreacted,
which would be 1 minus P.
So I could write down that the
probability of being a monomer
is equal to 1 minus P. The
probability of being a dimer
is equal to P times 1 minus P.
What's the probability of being
a trimer?
P squared times 1 minus
P. And in general,
the probability
of being an n-mer
is equal to P n minus
1 times 1 minus P.
So now you guys are
statistical polymer chemists.
So this derivation was
derived by a guy named Flory.
He got the Nobel Prize.
He's a pretty important guy.
If you want to learn
a lot about him,
I think both Professor
Cohen and Professor
Rutledge teach classes
that are basically, learn
what Mr. Flory figured out.
Well, maybe that's a little bit
too strong, but pretty much.
There's another guy
named [INAUDIBLE]
that did a bit too, so
[INAUDIBLE] and Flory.
Basically everything
about polymers
worked out by at these guys.
And all they did was
just probability theory,
so it was a piece of cake.
And so this is the probability
that you have an n-mer.
So now we can
compute things like,
what is the expectation
value of the chain length?
How many guys link together?
And that's defined
to be the sum of n
times the probability of n.
So that, in this case, is
going to be sum of n times P
to the n minus 1
times 1 minus P.
Now, a lot of these kinds
of simple series summations,
there's formulas for it.
And maybe in high school, you
guys might have studied series.
I don't know if you remember.
And so you can look up.
And some of these have
analytical formulas
that are really simple.
But you can just
leave it this way too,
because you get a
value numerically
with MATLAB, no trouble.
You can also figure out what is
the concentration of oligomers
with n units in them.
And so that's going to be equal
to the total concentration
of polymers times the
probability that it has n.
So this one, we just worked out.
The total concentration,
a way to figure
that out is to
think about there's
one monomer or one monomer--
I'll call this a polymer too.
This is a polymer with one unit.
There's one polymer molecule per
unreacted end, unreacted D end.
So it's really, I want to
know how many are unreacted.
So that's going to be 1 minus
P times the amount of monomer
I had to start with.
It could be A or D.
It doesn't matter.
It's like, how many of them--
I started with a certain
amount of free ends.
What fraction of them
have reacted based on 1
minus P. Yeah, it's 1 minus P.
So as P goes--
well, yeah, it goes backwards.
Yeah, as P goes to infinity--
I think that's right.
Yeah, when P is--
well, I'm totally
confused here now.
1 minus P sound right?
Maybe I did the
reasoning backwards.
This is definitely
the right formula.
I'm just confusing
myself with my language.
This is a, at least
for me, endemic problem
with probability is you
could say things very glibly.
You've got to think of
exactly what you mean.
So the concentration
of unreacted ends,
so initially, this was equal to
A. It was all unreacted ends.
And as the process proceeds, as
P increases, then at the end,
it's going to be very small.
So this is right.
And the concentration
of unreacted ends
is equal to the
total concentration
of polymers, the number
of polymers [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's this times P n
minus 1 times [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, and this is called
the Flory redistribution.
And that gives the
concentrations of all
your oligomers after
you do a polymerization
if they're all uncorrelated
and you don't form any loops.
It's often very
important to know
the width of the distribution.
If you make a polymer, you
want to make things have
as monodisperse as possible.
It's because you'd really like
to make this pure chemical.
There's some polymer
chain length which
is optimal for your purpose.
You want to try to make
sure that the average value,
average value, this is going to
be equal to the value you want.
So you want to keep running P up
until you reach the point where
the average chain length
is the chain length that's
optimal for your application.
If you make the
polymer too long,
then it's going to be
hard to dissolve it.
It's going to be hard to
handle and it's can be solid.
If you make it
too short, then it
may not have the
mechanical properties you
need for the polymer to have.
So there's some optimal choice.
So you typically
run the conversion
until P reaches a number so
that this is your optimal value,
but then you care about
what's the dispersion
about that optimal value.
And particularly, the unreacted
monomers that are left
might be a problem because
they might leach out
over time because they
might still be liquids,
or even gases that come out.
So this famous problem,
people made baby bottles
and they have some
leftover small molecules
in the baby bottles.
And then they can leach
out into the milk,
and the mothers don't
appreciate that.
So there's a lot of
real practical problems
about how to do this.
So anyway, you'd be
interested in the width
of the distribution.
So we define what's
called the variance.
And the variance of n
is written this way.
And it's just defined
to be the expectation
value of n squared minus the
expectation value of n squared.
These two are always different
or almost always different,
so it's not 0.
So this is equal
to the summation
of n squared times the
probability of n minus--
all right?
And a lot of times
in the polymer field,
what they'll take is they'll
take the square root of this
and they'll compare
sigma n divided
by expectation value of n.
This is a dimensionless
number because sigma n
will have the dimensions.
Sigma squared is
dimensions n squared.
This is dimensions of n, so
it's a dimensionless number.
And that's-- I think they
call it dispersity of polymer,
something like that.
Now, notice that when we
use these [INAUDIBLE],,
when we wrote it this
way, it's implicitly
that these things are
divided by the summation
of the probability of n.
But because these
probabilities sum to 1,
I can just leave it out.
But sometimes, it
may be difficult
for you to figure out exactly
what the probabilities are
and you'll need a scaling
factor to force this thing
to be equal to 1.
So sometimes, people leave
these in the denominator.
There's another thing
you might care about,
which would be like, what's
the weight percent of Pn?
So what fraction of the
weight of the polymer
is my particular oligomer, Pn?
[INAUDIBLE] sorry,
some special one, Pm.
And I want to know
its weight percent.
So that's going to be
equal to the weight of Pm
in the mix divided
by the total weight.
So that's equal to
the weight of m times
the probability of m divided
by the total weight, which
is going to be the
weight of all these guys,
times the probability
of each of them.
And you can see
this is different.
This is not the same as--
not equal to, right?
It's not the same thing.
So just watch out
when you do this.
And in fact, in the polymer
world, they always have to say,
I did weight average.
I did number average,
because they're different.
Is this OK?
Yeah?
So I would-- my general
confidence, at least for me,
if I skip steps, I always get
it wrong when I do probability.
So don't skip steps.
Do it one by one by one,
what you really mean.
Then you'll be OK.
All right, now, this is
a cute little example.
It's discrete variables.
It's easy to count everything.
Very often, we care about
probability distributions
of continuous variables.
And we have to do those
probability density functions
that I talked about last time
which have units in them.
And so as we
mentioned last time,
if you want to know
the probability
that a continuous variable, that
x is a member of this interval,
the probability this is true is
equal to Px of x hat times dx.
And so this quantity
has units of 1
over x, whatever
the units of x are.
And then you have to
multiply it by x in order
to get the units to be
dimensionless, which
is what the probability is.
And this is like obvious things,
like P Px of x prime dx prime.
[INAUDIBLE] value as possible
of x has got to be equal to 1.
It's a probability,
which is the same
as saying that probability of
x is some value anywhere is 1.
So there's some
[INAUDIBLE] you measure.
And you can also have a
probability that x is less than
or equal to x prime.
And that's the integral
from negative infinity
to x prime of Px of x dx.
And the mean is just
the integral of x Px.
And you can compute
the x squared.
The average of x and
x squared, same thing.
You average of anything.
You can put these together.
You can get sigma x squared
is equal to x squared
minus the average squared.
So that's the variance of x.
You can also do this
with any function.
So you can say that the
average value of a function
is equal to the integral
of f of x Px of x dx.
This is an average
value of a function
of a random variable described
by probability density
function with P of x.
And then you can get
things like sigma
f squared is equal to the
integral of f of x, quantity
squared, Px of x minus--
all right?
Everything's OK?
Yeah.
All right, so a lot of times,
people are going to say,
we do sampling from Px.
So sampling from Px means
that we have some probability
distribution function,
Px of x, and we
want to have one value of x that
we draw from that probability
distribution.
When we say it that
way, we mean that we're
more likely to find x's
where Px has a high value
and we're less likely to
draw an x value that Px
has a low value.
So that's what's sampling from.
Now, you can do
that mathematically
using random number generators
in MATLAB, for example,
and we'll do that sometimes.
But you do it all the time
when you do experiments.
So the experiment has some
probability density function
that you're going
observe something,
you're going to
measure something.
And you don't know what
that distribution is,
but every time you
make a measurement,
you're sampling from
that distribution.
So that's the key
conceptual idea
is that there is a Px of x
out there for our measurement.
So you're trying to
measure how tall I am.
Every time you
measure it, you're
drawing from a distribution
of experimental measurements
of Professor Green's height.
And there is some Px of x
that exists even though you
don't know what it is.
And each time you
make the measurement,
you're drawing numbers
from that distribution.
And if you draw a lot of them,
then you can do an average.
And it should be an average
that's close to this.
If you drew an infinite
number of values,
then you're sampling this.
You can make a histogram plot of
the heights you measure of me,
and it should have some shape
that's similar to Px of x.
Does that makes sense?
All right.
So actually, everyday
you're drawing
from probability distributions.
You just didn't know it.
It's like [INAUDIBLE] street.
The probability the bus
is going to hit me or not
and the bus driver
is going to stop,
I think there's a
high probability,
but I'm always a little
worried, actually.
Good.
I'm drawing from-- it's
a particular instance
of that probability distribution
about whether the bus driver's
really going to stop or not.
And if I sample enough
times, I might be dead.
But anyway, all right.
Often we have
multiple variables.
So you can write down--
you can define Px hat.
So now I have multiple x's.
It's like more than
one variable of x.
And I wanted the probability
density function of them.
I'm going to measure this
and this and this and this,
all right?
And this is equal
to the probability
that x1 is a member of
the set, x1, x1 plus dx1,
and x2 is a member of x2,
x2 plus dx2, and that.
That's what probability
density function
means with multiple variables.
So this is very common
for us because we often
measure and experiment
more than one thing, right?
So you measure the flow
rate and the temperature.
You measure the yield
and the absorption
at some wavelength that
corresponds to an impurity.
Usually when you experiment, you
often measure multiple things.
And so you're sampling
from multiple observable
simultaneously.
And implicitly, you're sampling
from some complicated PDF
like this even though you
don't know the shape of the PDF
usually to start with.
And so then when you have
this multiple variable case,
you can define a thing
called the covariance matrix
where the elements
of the matrix Cij
are equal to xi xj, the mean
of that product, minus xi xj.
And so you can see that,
for example, sigma i squared
is equal to Cii, but
the diagonal elements
are just the variances.
But now we have the covariances
because we measured, let's say,
two things.
All right, so suppose
we do n measurements
and we compute the
average of our repeats.
So we'd just repeat the same
measurements over and over.
So suppose you measure
my height and my weight.
Every time I go to
the medical clinic,
they always measure my height,
my weight, my blood pressure.
You've got three numbers.
And I could go back
in there 47 times,
and they'll do it 47 times.
And if a different
technician measured
it using different [INAUDIBLE]
and a different scale,
I might get a different number.
Sometimes, I forget
to take my shoes off
so I'm a little bit taller
than I would have been.
So the numbers go up and down.
They fluctuate, right?
You'd expect that, right?
If you looked at
my medical chart,
it's not the same
number every time.
But you'd think, if
everything's right in the world,
that I'm an old guy.
I've been going to the medical
clinic for a long time.
If I look at my chart and
average all those numbers,
it should be somewhere
close to the true value
of those numbers.
So I should have that the
average values experimentally,
which I just define
to be the averages--
this is the number
of experiments.
OK, so I can have
these averages.
And I would expect that
as n goes to infinity,
I hope that my
experimental values go
to the same value
of x that I would
have gotten from the true
probability distribution
function.
If I knew what Px of x is
and I evaluated the integral
and I got x, I think it should
be the same as the experiment
as long as I did enough repeats.
So this is almost like an
article of faith here, yeah?
It's what you'd expect.
Now, the interesting
thing about this--
I mean, probably
you've done this a lot.
You probably did experiments
and you've averaged some things
before, right?
If everybody in the class tried
to measure how tall I was,
you guys all wouldn't
get the same number.
But you'd think that
if you took the average
of the whole classroom,
it might be pretty
close to my true height, right?
So the key idea here
is that the sigma
squared of the x measurement
experimental, which
we define to be this--
maybe we should do
this one at a time.
[INAUDIBLE]
Then I can have a vector
of these guys for all
the different measurements.
So there's some
error in my height.
There's some error in my weight.
There's some different error in
my blood pressure measurement,
but each should have
their own variances.
I can have the covariances.
OK, so these are all the
experimental quantities.
You guys maybe even computed
all these before in your life.
And we expect that this
should go like this
as n goes to infinity.
Now what's going to
happen to these guys
as n goes to infinity?
That's the really
important question.
So there's an amazing theory
called the central limit
theorem of statistics.
And what this theorem
says, that as n gets large
and if trials are uncorrelated
and the x's aren't correlated,
which is the same as saying
that Cij is equal to 0 off
the diagonal, then the
probability of making
the measurement x is
proportional to the Gaussian,
the bell curve.
All right?
So this is only true
as n gets very large.
It doesn't specify exactly
how large has to be,
but it's true for any
Px, any distribution
function, probability
distribution function.
So everything
becomes a bell curve
if you look at the averages.
And sigma i squared
in that limit
goes to 1 over n sigma
xi squared experimental.
And this is really important.
So what this says is that
the width of this Gaussian
distribution gets narrower
and narrower as you
increase the number of
repeated experiments
or increase the
number of samples.
So this is really saying that
the uncertainty in the mean
is scaling as 1
over root n where
n is the number of
samples or number
of experiments that's repeated.
Now, sigma, the variance,
is not like that at all.
So this quantity, actually
as you increase n,
just goes to a constant.
It goes to whatever
the real variance is,
which if you're measuring
me, it might how good
your ruler or something.
It'll tell you roughly
what the real variance is.
And that number does not go
to 0 as the number of repeats
happens.
I mean, I could get
the whole student body
to measure how tall I am
at MIT, and they're still
not going to have 0 variance.
It's going to still be
some variance, right?
So this quantity stays
constant as n increases
or goes to a constant value
once it sort of stabilizes.
You have to have enough samples.
But this quantity, the
uncertainty in the mean value,
gets smaller and smaller and
smaller as the square of n.
Now, this is only true in
the limit as n is large.
Now, this is a huge problem
because experimentalists
are lazy, and you don't want
to do that many measurements.
And it's hard to
do a measurement.
So for example, the Higgs boson
was discovered, what, a year
and a half ago, two years ago?
And I think altogether, they
had like nine observations
or something when
they reported it, OK?
So nine is not infinity.
And so they don't have
infinitely small error
bars on that measurement.
And in fact, who knows if it
really looks like a Gaussian
distribution from
such a small sample,
but they still
reported 90% confidence
interval using the Gaussian
distribution formula
to figure out
confidence intervals.
So everybody does this.
If n is big, it should be right.
And you could prove
mathematically it's right,
but the formula doesn't really
tell you how big is big.
So this is like a
general problem.
And it leads to us
oftentimes misestimating
how accurate our results
are because we're
going to use formulas that are
based on-- assuming that we've
averaged enough repeats that
we're in this limit where we
can use the Gaussian formulas
and get this nice limit
formula.
But in fact, we haven't
really reach that because we
haven't done enough repeats.
So anyway, this is
just the way life is.
That's the way life is.
And I think there's even
discussions in statistics
journals and stuff about how
to make corrections and use
slightly better forms that get
the fact that your distribution
of the mean doesn't narrow
down to a beautiful Gaussian
so fast.
It has some stuff in the tails.
People talk about that,
like low probability
events out in the tails of
distributions, stuff like that.
So that's a big
field of statistics.
I don't know too much
about it, but it's like--
I mean, it's very
practical because--
now unfortunately, oftentimes
in chemical engineering,
we make so few repeats
that we have no chance
to figure out what the tails
are doing, maybe [INAUDIBLE]
our tails.
And so this is a big problem
for trying to make sure
you really have things right.
So I would say in general,
this is an optimistic estimate
of what the uncertainty
in the mean is.
Uncertainties are
usually bigger.
So you shouldn't be surprised
if your data doesn't
match a model brilliantly well
as predicted by this formula.
Now, if it's off by some
orders of magnitude,
you might be a little alarmed.
And that might be the
normal situation, too.
But anyway, if it's just
off by a little bit,
I wouldn't sweat it
because you probably
haven't done enough repeats
to be entitled to such
a beautiful result as this.
We can write a similar--
actually, so here I assumed
that the x's are uncorrelated.
That's almost never true.
If you actually numerically
evaluate the C's, usually
they have off-diagonal elements.
For example, my weight
and my blood pressure
are probably correlated.
And so you wouldn't expect them
to be totally uncorrelated.
And so there's another
formula like this.
It's given in the
notes by Joe Scott
that includes the covariance.
And you just get a different
form of what you'd expect, OK?
And the covariance should also
converge roughly as 1 over n
if you have enough samples.
So you should eventually
get some covariance.
You can write very
similar formulas
like this for functions.
So if I have a function
f of x and that's
really what I care about--
remember, I said that I
have the average value of f
is equal to f of x Px of x dx.
And I could make this
vectors if I want.
And I could repeat my function,
and I'd get some number.
And I could repeat the variance.
I have a sigma f.
And this is something I
like to do a lot of times.
Then if we do
experimental delta f--
so we don't know what the
probability distribution
function is usually, or often.
So we'll try to evaluate
this experimentally.
This is going to be
1 over n, the values
f of x little n, the n-th trial.
And we could write a
similar thing for sigma f,
which I just did right there.
You can do the same thing.
Just make these
experimental values now.
The sigma f squared
experimental should go to 1
over n times the variance.
And this was the sigma in
the mean of f, 1 over n
times the variance of the sigma.
All right, so this is
the same beautiful thing,
that the uncertainty
in the mean value of f
narrows with the
number of trials.
So you have some
original variance
that you computed here, either
experimentally or from the PDF.
Experimentally is fine.
And then now you want
to know the uncertainty
in the mean value,
and that drops down
with the number of trials in the
number of things you average.
So this all leads
in two directions.
What we're going
to talk about first
is about comparing
models versus experiments
where we're sampling by
doing the experiment.
So that's one really
important direction,
maybe the most important one.
But it also suggests ways you
could do numerical integration.
So if I wanted to
evaluate an integral
that looks like this,
f of x P of x dx,
and if I had some way
to sample from Px,
then one way to evaluate
this numerical integral
would be to--
sorry, I made this
vector [INAUDIBLE] a lot
of species there, a
lot of directions.
If I want to evaluate
this multiple integral--
it's a lot of integrals
for every dimension of x--
that would be very
hard to do, right?
We talked about in
[INAUDIBLE],, if you
get more than about three or
four of these integral signs,
usually you're in big trouble
to evaluate the integral.
But you can do it by what's
called Monte Carlo sampling
where you sample from P of x
and just evaluate the value of f
at some particular x
points you pull as a sample
and just repeat their average.
And the average of
those things should
converge, according
to this formula,
as you increase the
number of samples.
And so that's the whole
principle of Monte Carlo
methods, and we'll come back
to that a little bit later.
And you can apply that
to a lot of problems.
Basically, any problem you have
in numerics, you have a choice.
You can use deterministic
methods or stochastic methods.
Deterministic methods,
if you can do them,
usually are the fastest
and more accurate,
but stochastic ones are
often very easy to program
and sometimes are actually
the fastest way to do it.
In particular, in
this kind of case,
we have lots of
dimensions, many, many x's.
It turns out that stochastic
ones are pretty good way
to do it.
But we're going to talk
mostly about [INAUDIBLE] data
because that's going to
be important to all of you
in your research.
So let's talk about
that for a minute.
I'll just comment, there's
really good notes posted on
the [INAUDIBLE] website
for all this material,
so you should
definitely read it.
And the textbook has
a lot of material.
It's maybe not so easy to read
as the notes are, but plenty
to learn, for sure.
So we generally have a situation
where we have an experiment.
And what do we have
in the experiment?
We have some knobs.
These are things
that we can change.
So we can change
some valve positions.
We can change how
much electricity
goes into our heaters.
We can change the setting on
our back pressure regulator.
We can change the chemicals
we pour into the system.
So there's a lot of
knobs that we control.
And I'm going to
call the knobs x.
And then we have parameters.
And these are other
things that affect
the result of the
experiment that we
don't have control over.
And I'm going to
call those theta.
So for example, if I do
a kinetics experiment,
it depends on the
rate coefficients.
I have no control of
the rate coefficients.
They're going to [INAUDIBLE]
by God, as far as I know.
So they're some numbers,
but they definitely affect
the result. And if the
rate coefficient had
a different value, I would
get a different result
in the kinetic experiment.
The molecular weight of sulfur,
I have no control over that.
That's just a parameter.
But if I weigh something and it
has a certain number of atoms
of sulfur, it's going to be
a very important parameter
in determining the result.
So we have these two things.
And then we're going to have
some measurables, things
that we can measure.
Let's call them y.
And in general, we think
that if we set the x value
and we know the theta
values, we should
get some measurable values.
And so there's a
y that the model
says that's a function of
the x's and the thetas.
Now, I write this as a
simple function like this.
This might be
really complicated.
It might have partial
differential equations
embedded inside it.
It might have all kinds of
horrible stuff inside it.
But you guys already know how
to solve all these problems
already because you've done it.
You've been in this class
through seven homeworks
already.
And so no problem, right?
So if I give you something--
I give you some knobs.
I give you some parameters--
you can compute it, all right?
And so then the question is--
that's what the model says.
So we could predict
the forward prediction
of what the model should say
if I knew what the parameter
values were, if I knew
what the knob values were.
And I want to--
oftentimes what I
measure, y data,
which is a function
of the knobs,
it's implicitly a function
of the parameters.
I have no control
of them, so I'm not
going to even put them in here.
So I set the knobs I want.
I get some data.
I want these two to
match each other.
I think they should be the
same thing if my model is true,
yeah?
So this is my model, really.
But I don't think they
should be exactly the same.
I mean, just like when you
try to measure my height,
you don't get exactly
the same numbers.
So these y data are not going
to be exactly the same numbers
as my model would say.
So now I have to
cope with the fact
that I have deviations between
the data and the model.
And how am I going to
handle that, all right?
And also, we have a
set of these guys,
typically do some repeats.
So we have like several
numbers for each setting
in the x's, and they don't
even agree with each other
because they're all different.
Every time I repeated
the experiment,
I got some different result--
that's my y's-- for each x.
And then I change
the x a few times
at different knob settings.
Then I make some
more measurements.
And I have a whole
bunch of y values
that are all scattered
numbers that maybe scatter
around this model
possibly, if I'm lucky,
if the model's right.
Often, usually I also don't
know if the model's correct.
So that's another thing to
hold in the back of your mind
is like, we're going to
this whole comparison
assuming the model's correct.
And then we might, at the
end, decide, hmm, maybe
the model's not really right.
I may have to go
make a new model.
So that's just a thing to
keep in the back your mind.
But we'll be optimistic
to start with,
and we'll assume that
the model is good.
And our only
challenge is we just
don't have the right values of
the thetas, maybe, in my model.
And this is another thing, too.
So the thetas are things
like rate coefficients
and molecular weights
and viscosities
and stuff that are like
properties of the universe,
and they're real numbers, maybe.
They're also things like
the length of my apparatus
and stuff like that.
But I don't know those numbers
to perfect precision, right?
The best number I
can find, if I look
in the database
is, you know, you
could find like
the speed of light
to like 11 significant
figures, but I don't know it
to the 12th significant figure.
So I don't know any of
the numbers perfectly.
And a lot of numbers I
don't even know at all.
So like there's some
rate coefficients
that no one has ever
measured or calculated
in the history of the world.
And my students have
to deal with that a lot
in the Green group.
So a lot of these
are quite uncertain.
But there are some that
are pretty certain.
You have quite a big variance,
actually, of how certainly you
know the parameter values.
So one idea, a very popular
idea, is to say, you know,
I have this deviation between
the model and the experiment.
So I want to sort of do a
minimization by varying,
say, parameter values of
some measure of the error
between the model and the data.
Somehow, I want
to minimize that.
And I have to think about, well,
what should I really minimize?
And the popular thing to
minimize is these guys squared
and actually to weight
them by some kind of sigma
for each one of these guys.
So this is-- we should
change the notation,
make this clearer.
These guys-- one model, and
it's the i-th measurement
that corresponds to
that n-th experiment.
So I think that the difference
between what I measured
and what the model calculated
should be sort of scaled
by the variance, right?
So I would expect
that this sum has
a bunch of numbers that
are sort of order of one
because I expect the deviation
to be approximately scaled
of the variance of
my measurements.
And if these deviations are
much larger than the variance,
then I think my
model's not right
and what I'm going to
try to do right here
is I'm going to try to adjust
the thetas, the parameters,
to try to force the model to
agree better to my experiment.
And this form looks
a lot like this.
Do you see this?
You see I have a sum
of the deviations
between the experiment and
a theoretical sort of thing
divided by some variance?
And so this is the motivation
of where this comes from,
is that I want to make the
probability that I would make
this observation
experimentally would be maximum
if this quantity in the exponent
is as small as possible.
So I'm going to try to
minimize that quantity,
and that's exactly what
I'm doing over here.
Is that all right?
OK, so next time
when we come back,
I'll talk more about
how we actually do it.